name name one UFC guy that's beat a
boxer in boxing outside the UFC it's
never going to happen it's just not they
might as well compete in swimming it's
just the the I know both Combat Sports
doesn't matter you're talking about
apples and oranges you should be more
mad at the reason that the UFC fighters
aren't compensated like the bigname
boxers now the argument there is in
general from number one to 500 UFC
fighters are paid significantly more
than boxers the 1% the 0 1% of boxing is
compensated tremendously but those are
the guys that you know so you go well
these guys make all the money but the
UFC doesn't it's a different business
model you can name probably if if you're
into boxing 15 guys who make real that
that outlier money in the UFC I can name
a hundred guys who make a damn good
living it's just a different model it's
a product of the pay scale it's a shame
they they feel they have to do this to
get compensated